it's great to welcome to the program
today David Roberts who's a journalist
for Vox focusing on climate change and
politics and we're going to talk about
we're going to talk about a lot of
different things David great to have you
on today glad to be here so a lot of the
folks in my audience have been in a
concerned manner following what seems to
be the sort of the irrelevance of the
truth as it may be in modern politics
whether it's alternative facts whether
it's there's nothing Donald Trump could
ever do even hypothetically that would
make me reconsider my support for him
which we heard is the case for 62% of
Trump supporters some are just calling
this a post truth status quo in which we
find ourselves but is is that
encompassing enough how do you describe
what you see today is the relationship
between the sort of political world and
the truth as it is knowable sure well
that's a that's a that's a lot but
that's complicated but I guess the way I
would put it is that in any sort of
society or culture there's a bedrock of
trust with what what they call social
trust political scientists call social
trust which is just a sense that we're
we're in this together that we're part
of where they were part of a larger
project together and that whatever
sacrifices we make for that project
whatever restraints we put on ourselves
or whatever you know we have to do we
get back from that project and you know
we get food shelter social belonging so
a social trust is sort of the basis it
turns out for everything from politics
working and it turns out even to be the
basis of our information system so what
we've seen happen in the last several
decades is a erosion of social trust in
the u.s. I have my own thoughts about
who what who and what were the primary
cause of that but the result is that the
institution of media the institution of
journalism
as it existed in post-war America no
longer commands widespread social trust
there there is a large faction of the
country 30 40 % no one I think knows
exactly how large then simply does not
accept what what mainstream journalists
journalism tells it anymore and has now
you know the the conservative movement
lost trust in mainstream media separated
from it more or less went often made its
own kind of funhouse mirror version of
journalism but but it forgot to
replicate what made journalism work
which is some element of self correction
some sense that journalists are devoted
to principles beyond party beyond
faction that they're sort of answerable
to higher principles of evidence and you
know getting a second quote all these
were the day-to-day rules of journalism
are meant to sort of guard against
tribalism guard against sort of like
just telling us to worry that's whatever
your audience wants to hear when the
conservative movement sort of made its
own media it dropped that part out and
now we have what is effectively a second
competing media that is devoted just to
telling that audience what it wants to
hear not being answerable to any
principle above partisanship or above
faction so so we have effectively become
as a as a people incapable of knowing
things together which turns out to be
really important to democracy really
important to doing anything together
the first step is knowing things
together and we become unable we now
have a sort of a conservative media
apparatus that if it sets out to can
shield this 30 to 40 percent of the
country from any information it was it
doesn't matter how clear the information
it doesn't matter
you know sort of and I wrote the article
about impeachment which seems to me sort
of a kind of the perfect example of this
I mean the Trump administration cranks
out an example of this every every day
you could point to but impeachment seems
to me a poignant example in that the
story about what Trump did selling you
know withholding aid to Ukraine in
exchange for an investigation of a Viton
it's just really clear now it's just
really obvious we've got multiple
multiple direct testimony accounts Trump
has admitted it multiple times before he
figured out he wasn't supposed to have
done it multiple administration
officials have admitted to it it's got
documentary evidence there's something
there's a log of the call on and on and
on there's just this overwhelming pile
of information is just very obvious what
he did and why he did it
and yet as obvious as it is there's
thirty to forty percent of the country
that doesn't know it that believes all
sorts of weird cockamamie other things
about a giant deep deep state conspiracy
and on you know a server in Ukraine and
I don't even know all the all the
conspiracy theories that are going on
right now but but the point is we've
become incapable of learning and knowing
things together so it's not the truth is
gone the truth is out there as they say
it's not that it's not the nature of
truth that's a problem it is a social
process whereby we learn and accept and
act on that truth that's what's broken
one of the things that seems to have
helped some of these almost mean type
narratives take hold like for example
fake news is that there's some kernel of
sense in the idea for example that hey
we shouldn't just accept what media tell
us okay great that there's a kernel
truth there sometimes opinion and
reporting are blurred to your
disadvantage absolutely right I mean
that's how that's that's a important
part of what Fox News does we should
sometimes media gets it wrong and so on
but then it becomes
if it sounds like it's critical of Trump
it must be untrue without requiring more
examination and I think that's why it's
so pernicious because it starts with a
kernel of responsibility or truth and
then goes completely off the rails yeah
no I think that's totally right and I
think if you go back and look at
post-war journalism in the u.s. you know
the conservative movements critique was
always that this journalists class
especially as the decades went on is
worth composed of people who come from
the liberal class they're socially
liberal they're basically you know they
believe in tolerance they're you know
moderates whatever in that sometimes
shades news coverage in a way where
conservatives felt like people of their
persuasion we're not getting a voice
there was always a kernel of truth to
that but the question is what do you do
with that if if the problem is media
bias that sometimes ends up telling us
that ends up going against us what's the
solution
you could go two directions you could go
let's redouble the the rules and
principles that we use to guide
journalism let's redouble our commitment
to fairness let's redouble our
commitment to hearing all voices and
balancing all voices right or you could
go the other way here's a biased news
source that's telling us that's going
against us let's create a news source
that tells us what we want to hear right
and so the problem that they identified
if you look at what if you look at how
they reacted right they didn't react by
going and creating media with better
guards against bias right now gives or
better guards against unfairness they
went and created media that dis visits
with all guards against fairness and
just told conservatives what they wanted
to hear right so in sad looking back on
it it sounds to me like it wasn't the
bias that was the problem it was that
the bias went in the wrong direction for
them right like if you look at CNN and
your complaint is that it's not
objective enough and then you go create
Fox right
maybe it wasn't the the objectivity that
was really the the root of your
objection right
more the root of their objection is just
that we're not hearing what we want like
the results what we're hearing go and go
against us so we need you know we're not
gonna change our our persuasion or what
we want or our goals we're gonna go find
a media that will tell us what we want I
want to get your take on the degree to
which you think education is is a factor
here and I'll give you an example that
might be a good lens into it so the
Trump tax reform plan passed a couple
years ago and one of the things that it
did is not only did it changed tax rates
but it also changed the default
withholding tables meaning that when you
fill out your w-4 for your employer you
put I have one dependent the default
amount of tax that was withheld during
the year changed and you very quickly
had a lot of people saying the tax cuts
worked I've got more money in my
paycheck and then at the end of the year
you might have had someone who had $100
more in their paycheck per month but
their tax return fifteen hundred dollars
short so in reality they lost $300 net I
have I have argued that if we start
teaching critical thinking basic
financial skills epistemology early like
I say at age 12 in seventh grade that a
lot of those very base talking points
that are effective in politics would be
far less effective am i overstating the
importance of the education piece or do
you that there's something that this is
a really interesting question it goes
way back and I've been I've gone back
and forth on this I have I have come
down not on the other side obviously
teaching young people to think
critically is a great thing I mean I
mean I don't know that anybody would be
against it I do think it's a fantastic
idea and I do think especially in
today's you know media and information
environment it's just a jungle so
absolutely people need to be better
equipped to navigate it but I ultimately
don't think that we're ever going to get
to a place where we have created a kind
of like
super soldiers who become you know
immune to this stuff or or can't be
fooled by those stuff ultimately I think
relying on individuals to navigate this
is is fruitless because all individuals
ultimately no matter how good of
skeptical thinkers they are everyone's
subject to these kind of biases and
these kind of cognitive flaws everybody
wants to be told what they want to hear
like that's not a that's not unique to
any particular kind of person everyone
sort of especially if you're just in
sort of like the the rush of your
day-to-day life you're just not gonna
like hone in and analyze on every single
thing that comes out of the the TV you
know to sort of assess it yourself you
just don't have this or it kind of
cognitive energy your time so so to me
ultimately the solutions got to be in
our institutions we've got to build self
correction and self checking into the
institutional rules so for instance I I
think of science you know I don't know
if you've ever met scientists they're
not super humans they're not I mean you
know they're they're just normal people
they have in their day to day life they
have all the same cognitive biases we
have they're not super reasoner's well
because framework to work through some
of the right so it's like a conjecture
right of science they have the rules
it's like guild it's like a guild almost
there's guild rules you have to your
paper has to be peer-reviewed like
everyone the whole point of the exercise
is for everyone to constantly be
questioning everybody else if you did
that a normal life you'd be a jerk right
but in the science there are these rules
that's how we do things and so what
makes it work is collectively right it's
not that any individual scientist a
superhero is that collectively by
correcting one another and checking one
another you can help eliminate some of
those biases and blind spots and sort of
grope your way towards the truth and
it's the same for journalism or sort of
name your institution it's it's
important to have good institutions and
rules and self-correction mechanisms
built into your institutions because if
that breaks down
ultimately everybody's just gonna
retreat to their tribal corners right
here you're not gonna they're not gonna
reason their way through it they're just
gonna find a tribe that they feel safe
with and say I'm gonna believe what
these people believe right I mean people
feel anxious with uncertainty they feel
anxious when there's no trusted source
of information and they go looking for
comfort and that's what kind of this
sort of tribalism is that that we're
seeing so much today once you lose these
trust in these institutions it kind of
becomes everybody for themselves when
you look at the antidotes so to speak
you're sort of alluding to it here by
saying that there has to be some system
that doesn't depend on any one person
having the sort of determination to
handle it themselves or to think through
it themselves can you give us in the
limited time we have left just a couple
examples of what that might look like
well just take just take journalism and
the rules of journalism I mean as you
learn them like you can't just trust one
quote you need a second quote to back up
your first quote because the the first
quote might be a flawed in some way or
it might have just you found a quote
that told you what you wanted to hear
and it might be the exception if you go
talk to other people you might find
other things just little rules like that
little rules like if you find an error
in your in your story you publicly
publish a correction even though it's
embarrassing to you and maybe the
institution it's part of the rules that
we are transparent when we get things
wrong just little bits and pieces like
that little rule guild rules people see
those in operation and it gives them
comfort that there's like the structures
in place that I can trust what comes out
of this institution and so I really
think we need to be doing two things
right now one is improving the
institutions right like there was a
reason there are good reasons people
have lost trust in our institutions I
think you know this sense that could
have they're rigged for the benefit of
the powerful etc etc I think all that
stuff is is valid so I think we need to
refocus on rule of rule of law not of
people right in democracy and in
to shion's to make those rules and we
need to find some way of reaching that
30 to 40 percent of people who have sort
of hived off from mainstream society and
bring them somehow back into the fold
because I just don't see how democracy
survives if we all know different things
if we're all effectively living in
different worlds I just don't think
democracy can can stumble on very long
in that condition that is uh that is
that is the great fear and the great
concern we've been speaking with David
Roberts who's a journalist for Vox
focusing on climate change in politics
check out his work we'll be linking to
some of it David so great having you on
I really appreciate your time thanks a
lot David